[Musique]
bonjour longtemps je me suis couché de
bonne heure ah non ça c'est pas de moi
c'est de marcel proust je crois bien moi
je devais ouvrir cette conférence par
une autre confidence
longtemps j'ai cru qu'il ne fallait
jamais rien demandé à personne on ne l'a
tellement dit et répété quand j'étais
petit et le plus drôle c'est que c'était
par des gens par des personnes qui pour
certaines étaient bien plus altruiste
que je ne le serai jamais qui ne
demandait rien mais qui offrait ou en
offre encore beaucoup parfois même trop
sans qu'on leur demande quoi que ce soit
alors pourquoi pourquoi ne rien demander
jamais il va d'abord pour ne pas se
faire remarquer vous me considérez que
ça n'était pas gagné d'avancé pour moi
et aujourd'hui encore combien de
personnes viennent faire un ted x avec
un chien combien disent non moi je
n'aurai pas de powerpoint
pourquoi ne rien demander aussi et bien
parce qu'on ne sait jamais à qui on peut
faire confiance alors le plus sûr c'est
encore de se méfier de tout le monde
l'esprit du paysan du bocage normand où
j'ai grandi et est bien là on n'est
jamais trop prudent ma bonne dame
et puis l'étranger c'était celui qui
vivait dans le village d'à côté et
l'étranger par définition mieux vaut
s'en méfier pourquoi ne rien demander
aussi pour ne rien devoir à quiconque
mois par fierté ou par orgueil que pour
ne pas être redevable on ne sait jamais
être redevable ça pourrait créer des
liens non encore ce n'était pas gagné
pour moi si je ne demande pas qu'on me
dise un panneau ou a repéré le petit
four que je convoite
je ne les aurai jamais résultat quand on
ne demande rien qu'est ce qui se passe
on est seul seul dans sa bulle sans
interaction on se prive de choses qu'on
ne peut pas faire ou qu'on ne peut pas
avoir
sans les autres et surtout le rapport à
l'autre
comment est-il soit il n'existe pas si
on ne demande rien
soit il laisse les rares fois où on est
obligé un sentiment de dépendance et là
c'est un miroir très désagréable qui
s'étend devant nous une possible
localisation pour ma part sur ce
handicap qui de toute façon que je le
veuille ou non m'amenait à demander des
choses et quand on a le sentiment de
dépendre de quelqu'un l'image de soi
franchement elle est au plus bas
alors on n'ose rien on se fait tout
petit la petitesse
voilà bien le point de départ c'est une
conséquence autant qu'une cause la
conséquence vous avez compris c'est
juste on s'efface de la surface de la
terre mais la cause comment ça comment
la petitesse peut-elle être la cause
d'abord définissons la petit comme et 3
bien sûr comme la petitesse d'esprit
comme l'étroitesse d'esprit oui mais pas
seulement
c'est aussi le sentiment d'humilité
maximale je viens d'une famille où le
simple fait d'ouvrir la bouche
stigmatise situe dans les couches
sociales inférieures
vous avez peut-être lu bourdieu qui
parlent de cette reproduction sociale à
travers le langage dès lors qu'on parle
patois qu'on parle fort on fait des
fautes de français
on est rangée on est catégorisé et je ne
vous parle pas de la façon dont on porte
les vêtements les beaux vêtements
le dimanche et non pas en semaine pour
aller travailler ou des postures qui
finalement 10 d'où l'on vient et où on
ira pas du moins si on n'ose rien la
petitesse qui a été la cause du
repliement ce fut surtout pour moi celle
de la minceur du capital social et
culturel dans ma famille y avait une
part d'analphabétisme
je ne vous parle même pas évidemment de
l'absence de réseau qui ensuite s'en est
suivie alors on se sont englués dans un
marécage
comment s'en sortir et ben moi j'avais
un atout de poids dans la manche le
handicap visuel
une fois qu'on a touché le fond de toute
façon on n'a plus qu'à rebondir et pour
moi ça a été grâce au handicap visuel
d'abord parce que ça m'a contrainte à
aller à l'école de la ville à 25 km de
là puisque à l'époque les écoles
communales ne scolarise est pas les
enfants différents et là j'y rencontrais
une institutrice formidable
elle a osé et m'a fait osé et m'a ouvert
une conscience politique elle c'est elle
qui m'a parlé des pluies acides c'est
elle qui m'a montré que les arabes
écrivait de droite à gauche en faisant
venir un de ses amis qui a écrit mon
prénom en relief pour que je puisse me
rendre compte de la façon dont on
l'écrivait le handicap visuel a été
aussi un atout parce que forcément
j'allais faire un autre métier que mes
parents ils étaient agriculteurs
comment voulez vous que je conduis un
tracteur ils n'ont pas fait confiance
pour ce soir il n'avait pas forcément
tort
et puis on a tout aussi parce que je
suis parti très vite à paris toujours à
l'époque pour elle dans un collège
il fallait partir un petit peu loin très
vite
au cours de mon adolescence j'ai su que
je serai journaliste que je voulais
l'être en tout cas pour la première fois
jose je lutte plus tôt en fait parce que
quand j'ai commencé à vouloir entrer
dans une école de journalisme d'abord
ensuite à chercher mon premier emploi en
10ème enfin vous êtes aveugle
vous ne pouvez pas être journaliste deux
ou trois ans plus tard un mes amis très
chers qui était aussi aveugle et qui
était aussi journaliste double tard est
mort et alors on a parlé de lui en
disant qu'il était aveugle mais
journalistes on avait fait un petit pas
moi aujourd'hui je suis devenu
journaliste aveugle peut-être demain je
serai une journaliste
bref en tout cas je suis devenu
journaliste aveugle ou pas et à l'époque
je lutte encore plus que je n'ose et
surtout le peu que jose jeu seul et
parfois même bien seul jusqu'à ce que se
produise un basculement dans ma vie mais
là il y avait un paquet d'années qui
était passé j'ai à peu près 35 ans et je
me lance dans une aventure incroyable
qu'on appelle dans tes yeux qui était
une émission que j'ai incarné pour arte
on a réalisé 80 épisodes de 26 minutes
de voyage de découverte à travers le
monde
et là j'ai compris qu'on pouvait oser
demander beaucoup à tout le monde
notamment un jour au travers de ce que
disait une de mes collègues sahara pour
ne pas la nommer qui disais à quelqu'un
qui ont demandé de refaire une scène
vous savez les journalistes sont très
mal élevé ils demandent toujours des tas
de choses et sarah en l'occurrence c'est
une journaliste et plus respectueuse que
je connaisse des gens donc que elles
disent qu'on était mal élevés je me
disais que c'était pas si grave
j'ai compris à cette occasion qu'une
autre vision du monde était possible un
monde qui est en fait une toile une
toile à deux sens du terme 200 ce qui
nous donne une double responsabilité
d'abord celle de la ti c est donc de
tisser des liens
je sais que je dois et je sais que je
dois beaucoup à cette institutrice dont
je vous parlais tout à l'heure et à
beaucoup d'autres aussi et j'ai enfin
compris aussi que peut-être on me devais
parfois quelque chose il ne s'agit pas
d'une symétrie
par exemple on me donne des choses que
je ne donnerai jamais ne comptez pas
trop sur moi pour covoiturer avec vous
en tout cas pas moi au volant mais en
revanche compter sur moi pour m'inscrire
dans une réciprocité dans un échange
l'entr'aide elle ne va pas que de a vers
b et de b verra en aller retour
on peut aider à qui va aider ces qui à
son tour aidera b c comme un soleil
il ya des rayons qui partent dans toutes
les directions
la vie le monde est une toile aussi dans
un deuxième sens qui nous donne une
deuxième responsabilité celle du fait
qu'on doit la peindre
on doit la peindre chaque jour cette
toile je m'appuie un petit peu là sur un
grand philosophe que vous reconnaîtrez
très probablement on l'appelait jean
paul sartre
nous faisons apparaître le monde et sa
seule vaut qu'on existe nous sommes
notre rapport au monde
nous ne sommes rien d'autre mais rien de
moins non plus nous révélons au monde
nous le faisons surgir du néant et ce
dans un rapport à soi mais aussi dans un
dépassement de soi et notamment en
allant vers les autres le monde
c'est cette intersubjectivité et c'est
notre subjectivité qui le fait surgir
nous sommes à l'origine du monde rien de
moins dès lors si on n'ose pas si on
n'ose rien qu'est ce qu'on va faire
surgir du néant
on doit faire surgir autre chose que le
néant et donc il faut oser mais oser
qu'est ce que c'est la témérité pas tant
c'est plutôt sortir de sa zone de
confort faire surgir l'inconnu kit
d'abord à déstabiliser l'ensemble
mais il faut bien déstabiliser pour
avancer sinon on ne fait que reproduire
on reproduit une société bloquée ont
créé des individus qui n'ont aucune
perspective d'évolution le simple fait
de marcher illustre bien que pour
avancer il faut se déstabiliser le corps
bascule d'abord vers l'avant on peut
tomber évidemment les c'est rare oser
c'est surtout oser faire confiance faire
confiance par principe et grandir
l'autre nous grandir a aussi dans le
miroir puisque on partage une essence
commune et ça nous grandir a aussi dans
les faits par là même on devient
responsables de nos actes et de l'autre
aussi
on tisse ont créé et il n'y a pas de
liberté sans cette responsabilité et je
ne serai pas libre si vous ne l'êtes pas
il n'y a pas de liberté des uns sans
liberté des autres resterait à définir
cette liberté bien sûr qui pourrait être
l'objet d'un autre tedx que d'autres
ferait mieux que moi moi je vais me
cantonner à oser c'est osé qui parfois
peut aller jusqu à la désobéissance
jusqu'à ce désobéir à soi même je le
disais il faut sortir de sa zone de
confort parce qu obéir finalement c'est
se décharger sur l'autre du poids de
notre liberté
d'ailleurs camus écrivait une phrase que
j'aime beaucoup la révolte nous tient
toujours debout dans le mouvement
informe et furieux de l'histoire camus
distingue consentement et résignation
le premier est le premier dans notre
rapport au monde d'abord on consent mais
pour autant il faut refuser la deuxième
cette résignation donc désobéir désobéir
ce n'est pas seulement dire non ce peut
être dire ok oui mais oui jusqu'à un
certain point il ya une gamme des
désobéissances il faut commencer par se
demander pourquoi pourquoi telle chose
alors la révolte devient possible
la révolte pas nihilisme il faut bien
tenir à quelque chose au monde pour
avoir envie de le transformer voire pour
avoir envie de se mettre en danger et
pour ça il faut tenir à des valeurs qui
sont parfois même supérieurs à notre
survie
que serait notre monde sans de grands
obéissant deux grands désobéissants
célèbres comme l'ont été
candy ou rosa parks où martin luther
king
franchement quel courage
il a fallu à rosa parks dans une
amérique ségrégationniste pour refuser
de se lever dans le bus l'auteur
américain à louis josh farro dans un
ouvrage qui s'appelle la désobéissance
civile et qui est paru en 1949 dans un
écrit dans une amérique toujours
esclavagiste dit que ce kit ce n'est pas
ou du moins pas seulement le bulletin
qu'on glisse dans l'urne tous les ans
mais c'est l'homme dans la rue cet homme
qu'on met dans la rue tous les jours
alors moi le 15 mai une femme dans la
rue celle que je promène sur les
trottoirs tous les jours si elle ne sait
qu'une chose c'est celle là il faut
demander aux autres et beaucoup
en premier lieu il faut leur demander
l'audace sans elle on n'apprend rien on
ne change rien on se résigne au bout du
compte on meurt avec elle on comprend on
change soi même et le monde
on invente on vit ensemble on passe du
je au nous on s'engage vers et pour un
monde meilleur
celui qui reconnaîtra la valeur suprême
de l'humanité l'essence humaine voilà la
clé qui peut justifier cette
désobéissance
ce plongeon dans le néant mais qui
permet de porter aux nues une valeur
suprême
la seule qui vaudra qu'on se batte pour
elle et jusqu'au bout partout tout le
temps
cette humanité dont jusqu'à nouvel ordre
nous sommes les seuls dépositaires
moi en tout cas maintenant j'ose je
demande
je pars aussi deux semaines tout seul
sans connaître personne à new york en
vacances avec ma chienne et pourtant
j'ai réussi à trouver des partenaires
pour me guider et pour courir à central
park un vieux rêve donc on y arrive
alors que plus jeune je n'osais même pas
aller seul au cinéma ou boire un verre
en terrasse le fait d'oser me rend plus
forte
je sais qu'on peut donner chacun à notre
place de cette façon une touche de rose
à notre monde qui parfois est si sombre
et ma plus belle récompense
vous savez j'ai eu pas mal de
commentaires suite à la diffusion de
vente et yeux vous êtes formidables bla
bla bla bla c'était pas ça ma plus belle
récompense
ma plus belle récompense c'est le jour
j'ai croisé une femme que je ne
connaissais pas en italie à rome
elle m'a abordé elle m'a dit je suis
venu en vain
tout seul je n'aurais jamais osé avant
de voir dans tes yeux c'est grâce à vous
elle avait osé grâce à moi alors alors
et si demain parmi vous quelqu'un de
vous osez aller même peut-être jusqu'à
la désobéissance
on se souvient du jour où il aura
entendu à roanne ce petit ok merci
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]